alô aí legal pode acontecer
boa tarde pessoal é pra mim é um prazer
enorme gigantesco tá podendo abrir o
pedex lages hoje eu gostaria muito de
começar com vocês algumas indagações que
queria perguntar pra vocês a há quanto
tempo o melhor de si nos últimos dias
nos últimos meses vocês visitaram e
utilizar uma praça um parque em passaram
pelas ruas pelo nosso comércio
olharam pra cima e admiraram a beleza
dos nossos prédios
gostaria também de perguntar pra vocês
se vocês conversaram nos últimos tempos
com os vizinhos de vocês
hoje a gente vive um momento muito
complicado movimento um momento muito
corrido
nós temos o stress do dia a dia a gente
quer chegar mais rápido possível nos
lugares a gente deixa um pouco de de ter
a percepção da nossa cidade
a percepção da nossa comunidade hoje a
tecnologia que nos ajuda tanto que nos
une vamos dizer com pessoas de outros
lugares também nos escraviza ela acaba
nos deixando muito reféns de um mundo só
nosso de um individualismo muito grande
só nosso e nós acabamos por não
vivenciar mais as nossas cidades
nem mesmo a nossa comunidade ou a nossa
sociedade
e pra começar a minha tal que contando
algumas coisas sobre apropriação eu
gostaria de perguntar pra vocês aqui
quem é que veio de carro hoje poderiam
levantar a mão eu vou mandar porque eu
vim de carro hoje tá eu também gostaria
de perguntar a vocês quem vem de carro
sozinho
hoje antes de tudo é necessário que a
gente entenda que cidade é um organismo
vivo a cidade ela modifica a partir da
sua sociedade das pessoas que se
utilizam dela cidade
não existe idade perfeita até mesmo a
cidade mais bem planejada do mundo têm
problemas
e hoje um dos grandes problemas que a
gente tem é o carro
sim paulo mendes da rocha um dos
arquitetos é mais premiados do do mundo
brasileiro
menciona em recente entrevista
o carro é um mal da cidade e ele faz uma
analogia muito bacana que é o seguinte
imagine pensa no individualismo que é o
carro
por isso a pergunta pra vocês eu com
cerca de 90 quilos
andando em uma máquina de três toneladas
sozinho queimando combustível fóssil
evoluindo e fazendo um enorme esforço
para poder me movimentar durante a
cidade dentro da cidade
além disso a cnt apresenta um dado muito
importante que menciona o seguinte 20
por cento das pessoas que são que se
locomovem dentro da cidade utiliza um
carro transporte privado e esse 20%
ocupa 60 por cento das nossas ruas
então pensa em tamanho do espaço que o
carro culpa hoje dentro do transporte
público
nós temos a utilização de 70% da
população brasileira e esse mesmo
transporte público ocupa apenas 25% das
nossas cidades
você vai fazer mais uma pergunta pra
vocês
quem aqui vai para o trabalho de carro e
deixou o carro parado cerca de 48 horas
não só o trabalho nosso trabalho
faculdade
gostaria muito que ele seguisse essa mão
só pra gente poder ter uma questão assim
segundo o site - um carro um carro pode
chegar a ocupar até 26 metros quadrados
parado 50 metros quadrados ele estiver
em circulação mas nos atendo apenas
soldado de 26 metros quadrados
você começa a perceber o quanto esse
carro lá paradinho ocupa de espaço
numa analogia à nossa casa um
apartamento hoje de habitação social um
apartamento pequeno vamos dizer tem um
quarto que varia entre 8
a dez metros quadrados pensem comigo
o quarto onde a gente descansa onde a
gente se apropria aquele espaço que a
gente usa e tem a nossa cara tem menos
espaço que uma vaga de estacionamento e
menos espaço na nossa garagem até mesmo
muitas vezes uma vaga de estacionamento
tem valor não só financeiro mas um valor
muito maior do que o espaço onde a gente
do que o espaço a gente descansa ou até
mesmo onde a gente estuda e tem todas as
nossas relações
então é muito importante que a gente
tenha em mente que o conflito entre
carros e pessoas precisa ser resolvido
porque nós temos um espaço muito grande
para carros e pouco espaço para que nós
como pessoas nos utilizemos da da nossa
cidade
existem várias cidades que já tentam
resolver esse problema e um dos grandes
exemplos medellín na colômbia
quem assistiu marcos percebe que há
cerca de uns 20 30 anos atrás nem era
considerado um dos piores cidades do
mundo para se viver por causa da
violência
atualmente medellín já é considerada uma
das melhores cidades do mundo para se
viver porque eles tentaram a todo custo
resolver o problema desses conflitos
eles criaram áreas novas
esse carão de retiraram os carros das
ruas
criaram ambientes é de paisagem urbana
políticas urbanas para que as pessoas
pudessem se apropriar mais uma das
coisas mais fantásticas criaram nas
favelas
eles criaram equipamentos como os bi
como bibliotecas entre outros ginásios
de esportes e isso eles começaram a ver
que nessas favelas pessoas conseguiam se
apropriar e as cuidavam daquilo começou
a ter uma nova uma nova dimensão e uma
nova modificação nesses ambientes com
pequenos pontos
fora isso um bom método que a gente tem
de solução transporte público e as novas
economias uma economia compartilhada é
muito importante para a solução dos
problemas com o carro
nesse dado às pessoas que levantaram a
mão do carro
pensem que bacana você indo trabalhar
nos seus no seu trabalho com seu colega
e tirando um carro
se você e seu colega dividirem um carro
para trabalhar você remove um carro são
cerca de 26 metros quadrados e se vocês
forem quatro colegas trabalhar já são
menos três carros
cerca de 75 metros quadrados a menos que
a gente poderia usar uma área pública
maior na área de lazer uma praça
pegando também esse link curitiba na
década de 80 90 resolve um pouco desse
problema solucionado com mobilidade com
o transporte público e abrindo novos
espaços de área verde em curitiba foi um
grande exemplo durante muito tempo de um
novo urbanismo
já miguel arquiteto dinamarquês
desenvolve uma teoria chamada cidade
para as pessoas uma cidade mais humana
uma cidade onde a gente retira um pouco
dos carros e trabalha em uma cidade em
escala humana passeios largos as pessoas
se apropriando do espaço uma cidade
muito mais humana em prédios escala mais
baixa onde a gente tenha mais segurança
negando link da questão da cidade mais
segura genial estudo uma escritora
norte-americana uma jornalista chamada
de mg cops da escritora dos principais
livros e urbanismo chama-se morte vida
das grandes cidades
esse livro ela menciona uma questão
muito importante a segurança nas ruas
porque ela sempre menciona o seguinte a
cidade com pessoas na nas ruas é uma
cidade segura os famosos olhos da rua
enquanto a criança está brincando na rua
o teu vizinho pode estar cuidando das
pessoas que estão ao redor pode estar
cuidando pessoas na rua geram mais
segurança
essa apropriação gera mais segurança
quem é que antigamente não vi uma foto
antiga que as pessoas década de 60
tenta que tem nos museus principalmente
aqui em lages as pessoas na rua as
pessoas se utilizando da rua a gente
tinha pouco carro fotos de festividades
na rua ou melhor quem é que cerca de 10
20 anos não brincava na rua eu brinquei
muito na rua
isso me faz muita falta me faz falta ver
que as pessoas não se utilizam mais
tanto da rua eu jogar futebol na rua
eu jogava atacou brincava de
esconde-esconde corrida via varava noite
dentro
brincando na rua incomodava infernizava
os coitados vizinho mas isso era uma
apropriação hoje é impossível alguém da
minha rua fazer isso porque hoje minha
roupa um alto fluxo de carro
então a gente tem um conflito muito
grande não vai deixar a criança brincar
na rua ou você mesmo vai se movimentar
enquanto um volume muito grande de
veículos
mas mesmo assim ainda tem uma praça
perto da minha casa
essa praça ela me oferece tantas coisas
por exemplo não tem um banco o banco que
é o equipamento talvez nos equipamentos
mais importantes que a gente tem que ter
uma cidade é no banco que eu posso
convidar um amigo posso convidar um
vizinho pra sentar e conversar
é no banco que eu posso me apropriar da
cidade que eu posso é admirar a cidade
que possa admirar os prédios
o banco que é tão importante a gente não
tem
a gente tem uma ausência muito grande
dessa questão do banco
eu ainda tem uma praça perto da minha
casa mas e quem não tem
como faz para se apropriar como faça se
utilizar de um espaço geralmente pega o
carro e vai até lá vai até um tanque por
exemplo images ou algum outro lugar mas
seria bacana se a gente pudesse estar
muito próximos o problema desse lugar
muito próximo do próximo da gente
são paulo um pequeno grupo se uniu e
formou um grupo para o fechamento da
avenida paulista durante os finais de
semana durante o domingo com uma pequena
atividade
eles foram até a calçada da paulista
colocar uma tendinha nos bank umas
cadeiras de praia e começaram a arriscar
brincadeiras lúdicas amarelinha várias
brincadeiras lúdicas no chão
com isso as pessoas começaram a passar
alguns achavam que era uma venda de
cadeira de praia pediu para comprar
então começavam explicar isso que não
que aquilo ali era um exercício
convidava as pessoas a participar
daquele momento a fazer as pessoas a
sentar ali junto e discutir discutir a
cidade trocar experiências e isso é o
mais legal
a cidade é uma troca de experiências é
uma troca de cultura
então com essa atividade eles começaram
a mostrar e cada vez esse grupo foi
aumentando foi aumentando foi aumentando
até que eles conseguiram pressionar o
poder público e hoje a avenida paulista
no domingo é um grande parque fechado
hoje você anda na avenida paulista no
domingo
você consegue ver bandas tocando você
consegue ver peças de teatro
você consegue ver as pessoas correndo
então hoje esse é um dos melhores
exemplos de apropriação existe um
documentário no youtube é em cinco
episódios que ele conta ele conta os
prós e os contras
então é uma experiência fantástica e
porque não a gente fazer isso aqui eu
convido vocês então a começarem a partir
de hoje a fazer um exercício com vida em
seu vizinho convidem seus amigos com
vida uma pessoa que seja passando na
frente da sua casa
troquem experiências pegue uma cadeira
de praia sentem na frente da sua casa e
começa a se apropriar do que é nosso
vamos começar a usar a cidade novamente
reapropriar ela com essa atividade
daqui a pouco a gente consegue fechar
uma rua a gente consegue ter um espaço
de lazer nem que seja no final de semana
próximo da gente e não só na rua convido
vocês a se aproximar apropriar-se das
praças da nossa cidade temos tantas
praças aí que estão abandonadas
quanto mais a gente usar mais a gente
consegue fazer pressão mas a gente
consegue transformar esse lugar e não só
depender do poder público precisa se
unir se a gente se unir cada um traz um
pedaço
era uma coisa a gente faz um banco de
uma praça que não tem essa união é
necessária para que a gente possa viver
a cidade novamente
eu convido vocês a transformar a cidade
num quintal da sua casa
faça uma cidade ser nosso novamente
é preciso que a gente volte a viver as
nossas áreas de lazer e é preciso que a
gente deixa um pouco o estresse de lado
meu nome é william furtado eu sou um
arquiteto e urbanista sou um apaixonado
por arquitetura por cidades por pessoas
e muito obrigado pela atenção de vocês